the crown season 6 part 1 takes place
between July and August 1997 depicting
the tumultuous final weeks of Princess
Diana with the writers taking artistic
Liberties that some may find shocking
the end of season five saw Diana invited
to Egyptian businessman's Muhammad
aled's yacht in San Trope the two had
established a friendship over the years
with Muhammad leveraging this to obtain
the thing he wants more than anything
else in the world acceptance into
British High Society in season 5 we saw
how he hired the king's former personal
Valley bought the iconic British
department store herods and let King
Edward and his wife live in his Mansion
aptly named Villa Windsor if we're to
believe the show's depiction of events
Muhammad was a master manipulator who
coaxed his son into leaving his fiance
actress Kelly Fischer to seduce and bury
Princess Diana
except he coordinated Diana and Dodie
being on his yacht and even gave a
paparazzo the coordinates to catch the
infamous shot of them kissing with Mario
Brena the photographer denying he was
ever paid by Mr alfed in fact The Show
Goes even further with its dramatization
of events while it's true that Dodie and
Diana had a love affair the show
suggests Diana had no intention of
marrying Dodie according to one of
Diana's friends she quote needed another
marriage like she needed a rash in the
face which is likely why the writers
here decided to explore this narrative
and it kind of makes sense it was only a
year since she divorced from Charles and
the absolute circus that came with it
would surely make someone hesitant to
marry so quickly it was Muhammad alfed
who pushed the story that Dodie and
Diana were engaged and the evidence of
such was the deoa we ring but that very
evidence actually works against this
Theory let's take for example the
engagement ring Dodie bought for his ex
fiance Kelly fiser that was estimated at
$200,000 while the D Wei ring a poultry
11,000 in comparison If This Were an
engagement ring surely Dodie would want
something way more extravagant
considering it will be photographed by
every media Outlet in the world in
reality this ring was most likely a gift
Dodie was known to give Diana gifts like
this cier watch a thanks for the week in
sandrope now I just want to take a
moment to acknowledge the absolute
attention to detail the production
designers have done here this is the
security camera footage from the night
of Diana's death alongside the set
they've created and you can just see the
care they put into it the show also
hints that Dodie and Diana's driver hry
Paul was drunk showing him at the bar
moments before taking the wheel a
toxicology report later found that enri
had three times the French legal limit
of alcohol in his blood Queen Elizabeth
takes a backseat in part one but also
faces a series of challenges both
personally and for the crown just as in
season 5 it looks like the queen will
struggle with embracing change deciding
not to go to Camila's 50th birthday
party because she does not approve of
the princess decision to divorce but the
Queen's biggest test will come in the
aftermath of Diana's death will her body
be flown back on the Royal jet will
Diana receive a royal and public funeral
and will the queen publicly address the
people in their time of mourning for the
Queen the answer is simple you're either
in with the Royals or out I always say
it's hard to be half in anything you're
either in or out but the gravity of this
situation is unlike anything the Royals
have faced and over the course of part
one the queen softens and ultimately
does what she thinks is right even if it
goes against tradition as my dad often
says sometimes it's better to be good
than to be right although Muhammad
al-fayed is heartbroken over the death
of his son he still believes this
tragedy Will trauma Bond him to the
Royals but when the poem Dodie wrote for
Diana is returned without any word and
the Royals essentially shut him out he
questions why he and his people will
never be seen as
equals an artistic choice I enjoyed
about the aftermath was the ability for
the ghosts of Diana and Dodie to visit
our characters it provides a way to
offer some closure and allows our
characters to see their own flaws
perhaps the most important of these
encounters was Diana with the Queen the
queen initially sees Diana's death as an
event that turned her house upside down
but Diana makes her see that's not it at
all they're trying to show you who they
are what they
feel what they need and the queen having
always been a beacon of what it means to
be British now must learn from her
people as long as anyone can remember
you've taught us what it means to be
British maybe it's time to show you
ready to learn too it's after this
meeting with Diana that the queen
decides to give a public address
offering a Mourning Nation words of
strength and compassion it should be
noted that the queen did face criticism
for waiting an entire week after Diana's
death to make this address in part one's
final scene the queen of Praise but for
a brief moment looks over her shoulder
almost as if sensing something the
weight of grief finally hits her and it
seems as though she doesn't know what to
say so she turns to her right perhaps
hoping to see Diana maybe she wanted
peace or approval on how she handled the
situation regardless it's bittersweet
that the final shot is of the queen
looking for help from the one person
that wanted her love and approval but is
now no longer around to receive it while
part one shows the grief stricken Royals
events such as William going missing at
Balmoral may not be true the show
depicts a deeply emotional Charles
whereas Prince Harry's Memoir paints a
slightly different picture stating that
the only comfort he received from his
father upon learning of his mother's
death was a pat on the knee one scene
that struck me as particularly
heartbreak breaking was Prince Phillip's
words to William while walking behind
the hearse Phillip not one to really
show his emotion tells William not to
react to The Grieving crowd while
William asks why they grieve for a woman
they never personally knew he says I'm
not crying for
her crying for you with the crown coming
to an end after the sixth season we
still have part two arriving in December
consisting of six episodes these
episodes are said to cover the Queen's
golden jubilee Prince Charles and Camila
wedding and the courtship of William and
Kate I hope you'll like And subscribe as
I'll be covering part two as well but
now I turn it over to you what did you
think of part one leave your thoughts
and theories in the comments below
thanks for watching please be sure to
like And subscribe and for more bad
takes you can follow me on Twitter and
Instagram @ thinkstory YT until next
time remember you're either in or
out